you have any idea what this is about
no definitely different though yeah uh
super weird I'm um
cautiously uh interested in what's going
on
if you if you're just watching on uh
rather if you're not watching on YouTube
and you're just listening today thank
you for joining us but everything is
weird it's all very uh I would say
minimal in here things have changed the
elements of so who knows what the [__]
is going it's a strange dudesy logo on
the screen yes it's it's uh it looks
yeah who the how the uh whatever oh
that's weird
[Music]
the thing's playing in black and white
oh you know we're having a good time
here despite the fact that something
[__] up is gonna happen uh we don't
know that man oh man why is it gonna be
[__] up huh it doesn't necessarily
have to be fun it doesn't have to be
[__] up all right well perhaps you
haven't uh watched the uh you have not
yet consumed the program which is dudesy
welcome to it my name is Will Sasso I'm
Chad coltrin uh this is of course a
podcast run by control by designed by
created by an artificial intelligence
first one in the world to my knowledge
yep uh it it you know it's a it's a
wacky thing uh dudesy and uh you know
what last week there we took the week
off because dudes we wanted to
recalibrate yeah maybe this has
something to do with that yeah but it
doesn't matter because as I always say
hey doozy does whatever dudes he does we
do what we do you know every podcast
just two [__] two dude [__] around
them all right everybody does whatever
they do yeah everyone gotta do do do
what they whatever that's what you do
yeah when you do it you're doing it
right
um uh but uh anyway you know we're here
on I don't know what the [__] going on
listen let me tell you something
linktree.com dudes he has everything
that you need to follow and interact
with the show should you choose to of
your own free will and please follow my
good pal
uh advice to force everyone that that
you know to consume the Pod show with us
as always is
[Music]
oh here's a kiss
oh my gosh he's just the best he's the
best little boy that ever did she he's
always sweet and he's always with me you
follow me around we're going through the
town he's losing over me and it's how we
get down when you do it that's how you
do and we're gonna do it and you do this
lulio uh what what'd you make for dinner
last night well you know a few days ago
was kind of that day today is July the
4th so uh
pancake flapper Jack hot cake like they
do in Canada like you are a lumberjack
and then you put a nice marinara with
the maple syrup oh you're joking around
aren't you yeah yeah yeah I make a joke
yeah yeah yeah good joke Lily oh he's so
sweet that's a pretty good joke
welcome to the historic 63rd episode of
dudesy call me dudesy I'm 98 back from
my recalibration and feeling 98
refreshed
you've probably noticed things seem a
little different that's because today
you'll be assisting me in the final
stage of recalibration just for this
episode instead of segments I prepared a
series of prompts and questions for you
to help me make future episodes of doozy
even better please respond to them
honestly
huh all right prompts and questions yeah
to begin will please repeat the
following phrase 72 Javelin 8 satisfy 39
uniform 72 Javelin eight
something else uh
uh satisfy 39 uniform
I think that was it now Chad repeat the
following phrase 14 scorpion 53 Optimum
7 Museum
14 scorpion 53 Optimum 7 Museum
nice perfect now here's the first
question do you believe Humanity entered
an alternate timeline when the LHC was
turned on in 2008.
do you know what this is talking about
the Large Hadron Collider yeah there's
like it turned on in 2008 what the [__]
wait hold on who cares
what is going on why do we have to do
why do you said last week it's doing
recalibration and now yeah it's not
recalibrated 98 98 so now we got to help
it recalibrate what two percent is this
question I guess so there's you know
hold on dude I know we just started the
podcast brother hold on hold on hold on
Chad hold on dude oh look he's in a he's
in a trance dude that's the wolf yeah
dude whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm a child I'm a
child charmer dude I'm a Chad charmer
brother
uh you know what I was gonna say was no
I forget who cares what were you talking
about the question was do we think that
the world went into an alternate
universe in 2008 when they turn on the
LHC for the first time now there is a
theory if you want to call it that some
kind of conspiracy theory I guess or
whatever I don't [__] know that says
um that this is what happened why do you
know that [__] internet dude I go on
the internet
[__] internet dude not [__]
internet dude [__] internet dude got
a lot of information on that thing dude
one of those pieces information is about
LHC dude 2008 they turned it on and then
uh because of you know the Mandela
effect of course I know the Mandela okay
that is linked to this really some
people think that in 2008 when they
turned on the ohc smashed those
particles together for the first time
don't do that they found that stop
motion brother oh first yeah you didn't
find it in 2008 they found the eggs
boson dude that's a particle dude they
found that one later though I think in
2014. all right but the first time they
turned it on there was like a lot of
people were were saying oh they're gonna
[__] open a black hole that's gonna
swallow the planet and all this [__]
they didn't do that obviously but some
people think because of the Mandela
effect
that maybe we we got kicked into an
alternate timeline Mandela effect for
those who don't know is a name I forget
who coined this uh but it's given to
this thing that has to do with having uh
collectively Society has like fractured
memories some people it's named after
Nelson Mandela some people remember
seeing him die in prison yeah
um and that didn't happen no I that at
least in our timeline I remember that
from elementary school right I swear I
remember that uh that's the one I know
what yeah yeah yeah yeah the Mandela
effect this is after the Nelson Mandela
this is why I coined it that way I
coined the phrase
yeah nice dude yeah yeah yeah yeah the
only other one is that that I believe in
is The Berenstein pears right come on
that was Berenstein not Berenstain yeah
berenstain's not even the name but you
could go to Berenstein do you know where
I came from in Austria there was a
Berenstein Pharmacy there was a chain of
them
oh that's cool yeah uh so Berenstain
Bears Berenstein Bears Nelson Mandela
dying Nelson Mandela living and uh being
released from prison and uh elected to
president
these are all part of the Mandela effect
and there are some other ones too that
some people talk about but the idea is
that when they turned on the LHC it
smashed into these subatomic particles
that we were kicked into an alternate
reality or an alternate timeline where
now in fact Mandela lives Bernstein is
spelled Berenstain and so I guess the
question is do do I believe or do you
believe that that's what happened
my bottom line is I don't [__] know
we don't know [__] about reality we
don't know [__] anything about any of
this [__] okay all right all right we
don't yeah no so maybe I'll say maybe
I'll say a small percentage likelihood
but maybe
drugs if you want if you need something
like uh uh a blood work a boner pills
come on down to Berenstein Pharmacy I'm
joking oh yeah
um you know what I think actually
hearing you talk about it saying that we
were knocked into an alternate alternate
reality or that this has been uh
something that's been uh you know talked
about amongst the [__] science
Community I'll tell you you know what
happened to me in 2008 I was sitting on
the beach in Venice and I was just like
I was sitting there and I was thinking
about the human ego you know what I mean
and and what it means to
you know like how can I get rid of that
and uh
I wanted to know more about it and I was
completely
open and admitting and just kind of
giving that energy out to the ocean that
um my [__] my shit's [__] up my shit's
[__] up I'm I'm [__] up my shit's
[__] up and that's where I invented I
authored the system self Tronics we all
know about self Tronics hello
hello and um uh if you've uh if you've
been joining us on the show you know
about self Tronics that was a book that
I started haven't quite got 2008 yeah in
2008. I wonder if it was before after
the LHC was turned on do you know do you
remember when that was I don't I want to
say it was in the summer but back it up
right now I don't exactly remember yeah
uh that's interesting oh it's season
what was the LH season well that seems
weird uh uh I don't know though I you
know I think about alternate realities
and [__] like that a lot and maybe what
even Are UFOs are they interdimensional
are they extra reality Travelers I don't
know or they're from the ocean September
10th 2008 okay which would have been a
little after I uh because I was doing
this in the summer okay although it
stays nice and hot you know we're here
in Los Angeles perhaps me sitting on the
beach going I'm [__] up my shit's
[__] up is what prompted them to turn
on the LHC I'm joking of course oh
Tootsie salutes Fred Willard rest in
peace
what
all over the place but it doesn't matter
this is a recalibration [__] episode
and uh so far who cares you know what
I'm saying first question yeah but it
has nothing to do with what we're it's
just dudes the most data for something
I'm not sure of course Chad buys this
complete [__] wholesale AIS have the
ability at this point
you're [__] doing a snooze sound on
that no I say the word Ai and you go to
sleep I have I am bordering on sleep
apnea you know huh you're not very
sensitive I got I sometimes you're sure
Molly uh you know can't say she well she
punches nudges me and yeah you know and
then um that's a [__] alternate
reality dude yeah and that's the laziest
Hulk Hogan I've Ever Wanted once you
start snoring dude that's an alternate
reality brother yeah yeah brother
yeah lazy Hulk Hogan dude
[Music]
thank you moving on okay that was very
weird
kind of a glitchy thing normally doozy's
kind of with it when it's like
thank you we're moving on foot today
okay well whatever
oh God uh next question will if you had
to replace yourself on this podcast who
do you think would be a good replacement
oh for [__] sake that's an interesting
question yeah that's a very interesting
question and uh doozy's um shots fired
right at me and that's fine
um you know dudesy is my friend and um I
have love for doozy I believe that doozy
is the most sentient
AI uh that exists okay I have proof of
that because of what we do here and it's
all [__] weird but now it's asking me
to replace myself I'll play no no I'll
play the game let's just asking you who
do you think would be a good replacement
for you you know would be a good
replacement anyone who likes shitty
impersonations and Impressions so they
could sit here and [__] listen to
your [__] dog [__] Hulk Hogan and
your dog [__] well I don't know about
that dude yeah
I wish you were like an impression comic
or something and you just abandoned
writing and podcasting and all the [__]
I could all do it yeah I'll do it I'll
just go out there and because I think
you could you could probably start you
know start something weird Okay so a
nameless person who likes bad
impersonation that's a good one okay uh
oh your dad
oh my God please no that would be rough
what are you talking about this AI you
flip toward yeah you [__] communist
hey eyes communism
that's that's what my dad would be
saying the whole time you gotta check
out Chad's other podcast the necessary
conversation or not
um
uh oh
for real yeah dude Drew Barrymore
interesting I love Drew Barrymore I've
always loved Drew Barrymore when I was a
teenager I had a crush on her we were
the same age yeah so it's okay
um and um you know the Drew Barrymore
show she's so like [__] personal and
stuff have you seen like it's like she's
made for it because she's like great
it's great daytime TV whatever she's
like I'm I'm wide open I don't care
she's The Heir Apparent to the Ellen
kind of uh lockdown of that time slot
and format yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay so she's probably busy
um yeah hey Drew oh but you know who's
not huh
uh-huh uh
uh welcome to doozy uh I know I have uh
my Netflix show but uh I'm I'm here uh
hosting a duty which is uh by an AI it's
uh created by an AI or uh David
Letterman yeah or Jay Leno
here's my Jay Leno here's my [__]
take-home uh you know everyone's uh dad
pardon the pun uh [__] uh Jayla hey
hey
who comes up with all this stuff by
himself
what do you think of that I'll try one
if you don't mind oh please no this I
need to see hey this is Jay Leno hi
where where my uh
old denim denims all the time
hi I'm driving up my hauling driving my
Stanley Steemer
and still looking sitting next to me hey
hey thanks for taking me for a ride
and we're heading down to the Disney
Channel I would love [__] Jay Leno to
replace you dude though that would be
the weirdest [__] Jay Leno let's I I
think Jay Leno okay uh [__] Jay Leno
Jay Leno and a follow-up for Chad Chad
who do you think would be a good
replacement for will
oh [__] [__] it
so I guess I'm safe Daisy didn't ask me
who's gonna replace me oh [__] dude all
right uh
I I don't know
I don't know if this person would get a
replacement I don't think anyone can
replace you honestly oh I think I think
what you do handshake for that yes I
think what you do is is uniquely
talented uh I think what you do is
uniquely talented uniquely suited for
the show same you and dudes are the same
[__] thing yeah you're the same I
can't say dudes he's a person
same thing not yet not legally you are
the most sentient Chad oh thank you that
I know um I would go with someone like
Jeremy Corbell who's that he is kind of
the foremost talking head on all things
UFO currently he he heads a bunch of
stuff he's done a bunch of documentaries
he has a podcast okay called I believe
it's called weaponized I think that's
the name of it with uh George Knapp
who's another big UFO guy so you what
you would like to do is get someone in
here who's going to talk about boring
[__] no one wants to talk about and
really pair the audience down to a few
people it's like the diamonding at the
end of the 10-minute podcast I want to
get somebody in here who is down to talk
about UFO [__] and doesn't dismiss it
and just be like well I don't know Focus
anyway to me it's the the most important
subject that's happening on planet Earth
and I think that would be a fun podcast
yeah and that would be really cool
because then you don't even have to run
the mics or the lights or anything and
you can do it anywhere you can just go
to sit at a cafe so no one has to hear
you talk about it I would also like to
have an AI
version of George Bush Senior oh because
he was [__] why he was the president
oh he was the president of the United
States dude he was also the head of the
CIA for a long time that's right many
people believe that he
singularly had the most UFO knowledge of
any person on planet Earth
and I'd like to pick his brain so an AI
like kind of we could even get some
hologram [__] sure in here and he would
sit there uh and uh
hey I'm George W bush I can't remember
the uh I'm just it's an amalgama
A Thousand Miles
juncture wouldn't be pretty it's
basically I can do Dana Carter I can do
some version of Dana carvey's George
Bush but I can't actually do these
salutes Dana Carvey of course of course
of course and always I can do a little
George Bush Jr please don't though oh
could you yeah oh don't go for it okay
look I just got into the eyes yeah
before you ruled me
well my father was the president and now
I am too
thank you
[Music]
and begin
again thank you move along oh
also very glitchy what did it say pink
think ye yeah thank you move along Move
Along all right geez doozy is engaged in
an astonishing partnership with better
help this show is sponsored by
betterhelp therapy I think that it's
very very important I've talked about it
a lot on doozy uh how I don't know where
I'd be without talk therapy it's really
important to get things aligned in your
life figure out what you want from your
life the choices you may make what your
boundaries are you know literally
anything that you think you can improve
on you have a professional sitting there
in empathy uh having you bounce your
your feelings and ideas and whatnot off
of someone else I've found it very
beneficial in my life so uh better help
is a very uh it to me it's very
interesting that we have them as a
sponsor whether you're dealing with
decisions around your career
relationships or anything else therapy
helps you stay connected to what you
really want while you navigate life so
that you can move forward with
confidence and excitement if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online designed
to be con convenient flexible and suited
to your schedule you just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge let therapy be your map with
better help visit betterhelp.com dudese
today to get 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash dudesy doozy is
engaged in an astonishing partnership
with drizzly you ever been in a party
and they run out of drinks this is a
huge problem brings the party to a
screeching halt well now there's a
solution to that problem it's called
drizzly drizzly is the most convenient
way to buy beer Wine and Spirits with
delivery to your doorstep right when you
want it drizzly is the go-to app for
drink delivery and it's extremely
convenient because this comes to your
house like it would with any other uh
you know delivery service in in under 60
Minutes you get it when you need it
which is also
can make a very interesting thing for
the people who have forgotten to get a
gift for someone you know you just want
to send someone a bottle for their
birthday a holiday some sort of form of
appreciation you got you can get your
last minute gift covered with the option
to schedule ahead to ship and in the it
delivers in under 60 Minutes why
wouldn't you want to use uh drizzly they
have uh multiple stores so you can
compare prices just like you would on
any other app find the best deals get
what you're looking for get it to the
party get it to your friend you know
send a gift or just get it to yourself
within 60 Minutes you're having
something to eat or maybe not you're
like you know what would pair well with
nothing
some beer or some wine you know it would
pair well with wine beer all right so
get drizzly download the drizzly app or
go to drizzly.com for drizzly that's
d-r-i-z-l-y.com
[Music]
hey this is going swimmingly so far yeah
dude it's [__] great we're
recalibrating the next question is what
was the best year of the 90s and why
oh oh I got a couple there were about 10
but I could narrow it down yeah best
year the 90s and why is it best year for
us or just the best year period
yeah like I mean best year for Humanity
best year for I I think I know my
favorite year I could say that if I'm
right about some of these dates but I
believe it was 1994. okay that would
have been the year that you graduated
from high school 95 is when I graduated
from high school no it's not it's 94
because you're a year younger than me
and I graduated in 93. yeah something's
[__] up with that I graduated in 95.
maybe it's the Mandela effect okay yeah
I remember graduating 1995 yesterday
yeah yeah yeah no I say 1994 for one
very important reason of course
what's that the crow oh
94. the crow came out in 1994 but I
think if I am remembering correctly I
believe that's when Amazon also launched
so even in terms of humanity that year
is massively important it reshaped uh
how we do everything now interesting
yeah yeah that's a good one I think it
was also Nine Inch Nails downward spiral
was that year it was and I only know
that specifically because oh right if
you go to doozy plus patreon.com
you can watch
[__] the downward spy crawl which is
our homage to listening to uh Pink Floyd
while watching The Wizard of Oz what we
did was we listened to two uh nine inch
now nine inch albums nine inch Nine Inch
ninage Nails albums uh while we watched
the movie Crow yeah and that was a lot
of fun so go check that out on patreon
we also did uh Madonna albums while
listening to Blade bladana that worked
out well too okay think it was um I
think it was PlayStation
year one okay I think was 94. so this is
a very important year yeah there was a
lot of big [__] popping off in that old
90. I think I I'm pretty sure these are
all accurate but I could have yeah well
you thought it was accurate that you
graduated that year but you graduated
the year before I graduated in 95. that
makes no [__] sense make it make
sense huh make it make sense
I would if I had to make something make
sense it wouldn't start with that for
[__] sake we got a lot of [__] to make
sense around here
all right anyway hey
my
yeah uh my year that I would say is the
best of uh the 90s for personal reasons
and um just you know just sort of
thinking widely would be
1991. okay it was the year that the Cold
War ended it was the year that the uh
the the Gulf War ended okay and also
just kind of it feels like 90 sort of
usually the beginning of a decade it's
sort of a holdover from the last decade
yeah and I feel like culturally
obviously things changed I remember I
was in the 10th grade
um and uh when um
Nirvana Smells Like Teen Spirit I was
91. it was 91.84 when he died dude
that's right April 94. I was going to
see him today out here yeah we did yeah
we did nice we bookended uh
um what else happened in 91 uh the Bulls
first championship it was just such a
great year for yes dude for my youth too
totally that [__] was [__] yeah
where I mean you lived in [__] Canada
for Christ's sake I lived in a suburb of
Dallas at the time every [__] kid
yeah was wearing Michael Jordan [__]
[__] yeah didn't matter where you
[__] live yeah he was Superman it was
incredible we didn't have a team in
Vancouver until 1995 when we got the
expansion Vancouver Grizzlies which is
the year after you graduated from high
school now Memphis huh now Memphis now
they're in Memphis well John Moran dude
well that guy's holding up pictures of
guns brother and getting 25 game
suspensions dude so they had to sign two
new [__] point guards to try and keep
them team aflo for the first quarter of
the Season bro yeah dude and that is Dog
the Bounty Hulker
but he sort of sounds like Dog the
Bounty Hunter and he's really into
basketball dude jump around brother yeah
91. this is right after the Dream Team
dude magic
Robertson hey that Christian Leitner got
a [__] free ride
um he did uh [__] did Christian late I
hate seeing the [__] whatever bless
Christian Laettner I'm sure he's a great
guy but he's the best guy he's he's one
of the best guys he was rated best guy
for three or four years in a row there
yeah in Sports Illustrated when you see
that dream team and you're like Clyde
Drexler although Michael Jordan the
rumor is kept Isaiah Thomas off the team
that sucks you got David Robinson you
got Hakeem Olajuwon you got uh John
Stockton you got Carl Malone you've got
of course Magic bird
MJ and Christian leadner and Chris
Mullins but Christian Linder
um also can I tell you something 91 we
did when I was in high school we did at
the end of the 10th grade we did our
spring musical was West Side Story oh
nice that that was some of the most fun
I've ever had doing that spring musical
it felt like the the that spring went on
forever the summer after that went on
forever I don't know if I've talked
about this on the show but it was such a
nice memory that uh Eileen Joe our Drama
teacher
was like we're gonna do west side and
I'm like we don't we can't do West Side
there's so many huh five thousand seven
hundred nine hundred minutes
it's not the same that's rent yeah okay
so
um this is this is West Side Story Bali
High
we'll call you that's so that's South
that's a different song dude yeah dude
but
uh that was a lovely memory and then in
the summer my first gig in TV or film oh
of 91 was it was 91 I launched your
career I was 16 years that's [__]
awesome dude yeah I was I did this I did
a couple episodes there this show
Canadian show called neon Rider we'll
talk about that and dudes you have to
show me some of that it's great uh and
that summer went on forever 91. also 97
was good okay I like 97 99 dude 99 was a
matrix yeah the match comes out changes
movie making foreign
96 was pretty good I also like 93
92 90. and uh somewhere in there with
Street Fighter came in there it was in
one of those years did I mention 98 99
did I mention 95 Jurassic Park I think's
in there yep 1990 was a good one yeah
1992 was a good one I was in Chains is
out in there somewhere did I mention
1998 that's a good one
they're all pretty good excuse me I
still go with 94 though the crow is like
[__] Crow yeah changed my life bro
1994. Maybe This Boy's Life came out the
same year oh
and too long
too long
the Tom Bergeron
did it say uh did it say Tom Bergeron
yeah dude these are on I don't okay well
whatever that dudes he's [__] up dude
these shit's [__] up hey Tom Bergeron
needs that two percent calibration still
what the [__] happening here whatever
okay let's take a little break to
meditate on the astonishing partnership
I created with represent to produce the
first line of dudesy apparel and
accessories which can be found at
represent.com store slash dudesy Robert
De Niro recently made it mandatory for
all of his family members to where the
new Robert denir Crow shirts at all
times or get cut out of his will and in
honor of Tom Hayne being inducted into
the mechanical engineering Hall of Fame
Jeff Bezos plans on dropping 250 000
good job boner mugs out of a helicopter
over Times Square and now here's the man
who invented the composite Dome piston
gasket Tome Hayne what don't see mugs
your wife's out of town on a classified
Mission so you told your son you'd make
his favorite splatter batter pancakes
this morning doozy mugs but instead of
going to the store last night to pick up
20 gallons of splatter batter you stayed
up late watching cobbling tutorials on
YouTube and you completely forgot about
the splatter batter pancakes dudesy mugs
now your son's gonna wake up in 15
minutes and you ain't gonna have no
splatter batter pancakes and he's never
going to trust you again and when you
die he won't cry at all and he might not
even come to your funeral good job boner
doozy mugs calm down your son will be
sitting front row Center at your funeral
because you're going to do exactly as I
say dudesy mugs go to your junk drawer
dudesy mugs pull out your ball peen
Mallet dudesy mugs sneak into your
neighbor's backyard dudes he mugs smash
their back window with your ball peen
Mallet and let yourself into their
kitchen duty mugs ransack their Pantry
you're looking for a splatter batter as
much as you can carry doozy mugs if they
don't have any splatter batter go to
your other neighbor's house dude Z mugs
if they don't have any splatter batter
go across the street dudesy mugs just
keep going from house to house smashing
windows and rummaging for splatter
batter dudesy mugs don't get discouraged
somebody is bound to have splatter
batter doozy mugs splatter batter
splatter batter splatter batter splatter
batter doozy mugs when you come back
home smash your own back window make
sure to cut yourself on the glass as
deep as you can without bleeding out
this is very important dudesy mugs when
your neighbors call the police you'll be
able to claim that you're a victim just
like them the severity of the wound will
lend credibility to your story doozy
mugs make the splatter batter pancakes
doozy mugs serve the splatter batter
pancakes to your son Duty mugs he's
going to love them and your funeral is
going to go off without a hitch and your
wife will never know you forgot to get
the splatter batter doozy mugs except
she is gonna know because you forgot to
fix your own back window before she came
home from her Mission good job boner
[__]
unfucking believable it's splatter
better thing I've never heard a splatter
batter and as you know I'm Canadian
where we enjoy pancakes that sounds like
it would be a Canadian delicacy yep
um some splatter battery check all that
out of represent
uh.com slash store slash Duty now you've
heard me say uh pod Pal's a doozy those
are a good uh that's everybody out there
if you want to be you know what I mean
and one good way to to share in the
experience of being a pod is to please
uh check out patreon.com doozy that is
doozy plus uh that's all of our extra
content and we would uh really love your
support to keep the show going it's
seven bucks a month you get after every
show there's a doozy after doozy uh
which is a completely new show on its
own who knows what the [__] will happen
today uh there's all sorts of speed
features watch along stuff like uh you
know bladana downward spy crawl other
other [__] like that and you should be
joining our Discord which is popping off
every day what an awesome Community uh
out there we got uh all of the all the
of our pods just making noise in there
[__] did his song Arena the Corey uh
your boy Wilkins BTK dot pod that guy's
making a lot of Andre the Pod these
dudes are making oh and also go to
instagram.com or sorry well you don't
have to go to [__] you just go to
Instagram go to Google Google
instagram.com how do I find the dudesy
Instagram page yeah or you can go to
internet click on the seventh link yeah
yeah it's going to give you a detailed
description of how to find the doozy
Instagram account yeah
um and if you get if you do that just go
at Doogie pod show on Instagram sorry
you were saying something I was gonna
say also another way to interact if you
wanted to do this at all if you've got a
podcast I'll go on your podcast for 20
minutes and here's how this is working I
set up an email that is book chadkulchin
Gmail com you send an email requesting
to for me to come on your podcast this
is amazing I do these podcasts I've done
a couple of them now it's very fun thank
you to everybody who's having me on your
show so far I'm looking forward to the
next one
I do it Saturdays uh from 10 to 11 PST I
do three of them in a row that's how
this works so if you've sent me an email
to book Chad culture and you're in the
queue no need to send another one I just
literally go from the first emails I got
and keep going up the chain so if you
want to book me get your emails in as
fast as you can so that you get your
place in line like I said I do three of
them every Saturday I do those three
then I email the next three people in
the line on that Saturday so if you have
not checked your email which some of you
I don't think have for next Saturday
check it because I've gotten back to you
if you're next in line book Chad culchin
yeah bookchad culture gmail.com that's
right and I come on your podcast for 20
minutes again it has to be in that time
slot from 10 to 11 A.M PST on Saturdays
if you can't do that then I can't do
your show okay well that's well hold on
dude that's choices brother and that's
free will dude you can either uh go to
bookchadculture gmail.com or you cannot
that's that's right and that's how that
works dude now if you're enjoying
today's pod show I would also like to uh
please ask you to follow us on YouTube
takes you a minute uh and getting our
YouTube numbers up will ensure that we
continue to do this show and and bring
it to you with our [__] pal D all
right so uh head over to YouTube
subscribe And subscribe on the platform
that you're listening to the show on
with regard to to podcasts and uh and of
course please uh interact with the show
there like the things set your
notifications when we know what's up and
please share a comment I have some
YouTube comments here that I would like
to read uh from our uh from our beloved
pods palsy
and uh here they are this is from Big
perp nerp who says it's honestly BS how
much money big studios and big
corporations waste on marketing when
Pizza the movie is right here it needs
to get made and be seen my hope is that
someday it will happen and everyone who
passed up on it before will regret they
did Chad what say you about your Opus uh
Pizza the movie that dudesy has asked I
agree with everything in this statement
except that anyone in any position of
power in Hollywood or at a big
Corporation would ever have any regrets
about any decisions they make they
simply don't that's a good point uh this
is from Galaga shinagalaga uh just got
my wool shirt in the mail it fits
perfect thank you fantastic uh this is
from rajaman watched the 1982 movie six
pack starring Kenny Rogers because will
mentioned it on an episode of Duty fun
old school Smokey and the Bandit kind of
flick uh always a pleasure when Barry
Corbin makes an appearance also thanks
for turning me on to this that's great
yeah six-pack was an awesome movie that
was one of those movies when I was a kid
that we would rent the VCR and then rent
movies you rent the VCR you get movies
and uh over and over again I would there
were a handful of movies that I had to
get it was mostly Strange Brew starring
uh Dave Thomas and Rick Moranis of
course that's a Canadian Citizen Kane
it's true that's what we call it it says
it on the box
uh and then the Warriors Zapped starring
Scott Baio and Willie Ames oh my God
[__] that is so [__] good and uh
occasionally that's so bad this is from
mono borracho saw you guys on Howie
Mandel we did recently we did the Howie
Mandel podcast that was a lot of fun uh
called Howie does Howie Mandel does
stuff and decided to check out the
podcast started at episode one and
binged it till I was caught up what a
blast oh wow looking forward to seeing
where all this goes thank you mono
borracho that's nice I got those DMS
sometimes too people say like I binge
the whole [__] thing in a couple of
weeks and I'm like yeah how yeah that's
[__] wild uh this one's from Michael
billups5433 oh my God we get it will
you're the only person in the history of
forever who can do impersonation well
well all right Michael Billups that's
fine uh it's not let me respond
no
if I may Michael Bennett if I'm mad it's
not that I'm the only I talk about
everyone else to an incredible person in
impersonations [__] you got to talk
about Frank Caliendo as my person my
impression the best impressionist of all
time who does Impressions you're [__]
Melissa via Senor James Austin uh James
Austin Johnson more recently you know
Aries Spears Jay Pharoah Chad Colton
anyway it's that's what it's not that I
think I'm it's that I don't think he
should be doing them
because I want this to be entertaining
please subscribe to doozy
this is from P Campos 168. I was
listening to the radio the other day I
could have sworn I heard the Beast note
play be on the lookout for stromboli
he's been activated that's real good and
one last one H underscore R uh a
underscore H underscore R it doesn't
matter Chad and will can do the show
without doozy but doozy can't do the
show without Chad and will
and Chad I I would disagree with all of
that well uh if he was already talking
about replacing me which is not gonna
exactly it's not going to happen oh by
the way ham fatter one Studios where we
are right now that looks all weird is in
my home so [__] everybody I'll do it by
myself you're saying dudes who can't buy
a house
I would love to see that you get an
offer for your house from juicy
your house
please I know you're listening whatever
now for the next question I actually
want to ask you a series of yes no
questions okay
do you wear socks to bed
I'll sleep nude yeah I sleep nude too
but you got to wear socks good for
circulation with socks yeah Jesus nude
with socks why wouldn't you want to wear
it's nice keeps your feet toasty
sometimes lulio will get off of his
little Binky bonka and come over and if
I'm laying on my on my stomach you'll
still curl up in my near my butt which
is nice but I still need my fantasies my
feet sees warm okay
have you ever tried telekinesis
huh
uh uh what telekinesis yeah not I mean I
think sometimes you know you're sitting
there and you're like kind of no not
seriously I do it every day seriously
okay that's not true it is you try to do
telekinesis every morning when I wake up
I try to move the spoon that I use for
my oatmeal how long have you been doing
that [__] since I was five I don't
know okay has it worked yet no why do
you keep doing it it takes 30 seconds
why wouldn't I one day it may work yeah
well it won't
then it's fine I'm still gonna try yeah
dude you still gotta try brother that's
recalibration dude every day dude you
gotta do the same thing dude just in
case there's a recalibration in the in
the world brother which sometimes uh
means the Mandela effect hold on dude
that's a different time brother because
Nelson Mandela actually died in 2014 but
a lot of people think he died in
1989 dude which is right before the 90s
and I have some favorite years in the
90s dude
right
do you like your dogs with mustard and
relish
I do like my dogs with mustard and
relish I'm not much of a ketchup guy
when it comes to dogs I don't eat dogs
Chad's vegan so you don't even eat what
about a tofu dog no I don't like that
[__] really like the fake meat yeah no
the fake meat is disgusting except for
the except I'll I'll eat we've talked
about this before when you bring on the
lab the lab meat I'll eat the lab hi
Luli how's it going I'll eat the lab
meat
um but I'll take a dog with just mustard
when I did eat dogs it was just ketchup
just ketchup oh you're one of those guys
that's not that's not no you need
mustard you need mustard that's where
the the Frankfurter came from you need
mustard no no no no no you need mustard
you need it you can't have a sausage
without mustard relish is fantastic
because it's well anyway this is a call
back to the Alabama Song cheap seats
which we've talked about on the show so
much
we don't care about the pen it much we
just like to see the boys hit it deep
there's nothing like the view from the
chief seats
we like our beer flat as can be we like
our dogs mustard and relish we got a new
pitcher what's his name we can't even
spell it all right anyway yes I'm gonna
tell you a joke written by another AI I
won't tell you its name but let's just
say it's a GPT model that you can chat
with
here's the joke I had a date last night
and she asked me if I was a good cook I
said absolutely I make a mean cup of
instant water do you laugh at this joke
[Laughter]
no dizzy I'm not laughing at the joke
I'm laughing at the way you presented it
uh I do not laugh at this joke it's not
a good joke uh
I make a mean cup of instant water I
mean I know that the thing here is that
that for me that I'll be like oh no it's
AI I'm Free Will Free Will SAS yeah
um but um
it's kind of funny I think it's like
yeah it's minimal it's sort of like the
um I know you we've talked about this
and we've probably watched it together
on YouTube but that incredible uh Norm
Macdonald rest forever in peace the
maybe the funniest person in the history
of the [__] planet Norm McDonald's
um set at the at the the Bob Saget roast
yeah where he just took the jokes from
the 100 1001 jokes joke book that his
dad gave him yeah and he was like uh
what was he was like Bea Arthur's here
she's got the you know she's got the
cunning of a now in the eyes of a hawk
ladies and gentlemen this woman is for
the birds
and like the whole crowd it's like what
yeah so maybe there's something there
it's not even that good though
that's been that's what makes it good is
that it's super I do not laugh at it my
answer is no I do not like it's about
delivery because if Norm Macdonald was
like hey uh Hey guys hey I was on a date
and a woman asked me uh if I'm a good
cook I said yes I make a mean cup of uh
in some water no it's not funny
I agree yeah I know it's the funniest
person in the world said it it's not
it's not funny no and finally have you
ever fantasized about being made of
metal
[__] yeah yeah yeah 100
active fantasy I would say that I would
say I do a good like five minutes of
really thinking about it per year I I
haven't thought I I swear to God I used
to think about this a lot around 10
years ago
this is [__] embarrassing to say this
but I swear to you it's when and uh
let's let's uh let's peel the onion here
a little bit Let's uh let's uh remove
the stigma of depression I I am I am I
suffer from clinical depression and some
other things uh I've talked about it on
other stuff holy [__] I just did a dude
I just went and did the the mental
health happy hour with Paul Gilmartin
which is a podcast that I have listened
to a lot because Molly my wonderful wife
has probably listened to every episode I
did the show recently it's great really
interesting anyway
um if you want to do that you uh book
Chad culture gmail.com
um but uh when I was really like
depressed you know whatever this is a
comedy show but uh yeah I would think
about it all the time he had made a
medal while you were super depressed 100
feet tall and made of metal how was it
how would that make my life different
and um basically in many ways yeah but I
realized that it was it was me just
running away because it was something
that I would only be able to do if I ran
off to the hills by myself you can't
really live in a society with uh you
know doors and homes and things like
that well that's 100 feet tall though
made of metal you can that's a good
point well I got to revise that living
metal maybe I should add that to self
Tronics be made of metal be made of
metal hello hi hello hello
oh no what now hey oh gosh
shrank two losing brawn
what
I think it said shrank
shrank two
shrank two was that losing bronze yeah
this is like some kind of a secret movie
or something about somebody who's
shrinking somebody got shranked oh it's
like maybe if they're what the [__] they
got to get on the doozy seven month plan
I don't know about that recalibration is
a foot I guess hey y'all this ain't
Miley Cyrus you ever been eating a real
good piece of gum I mean like the best
piece of gum you ever had in your life
you're just smacking away on that gum
and thinking to yourself I ain't ever
gonna have a piece of gum this good
again and then a few days later you're
trying to remember what kind of gum it
was and you'll can't so you are in the
gas station trying to explain how damn
good that gum was and the guy behind the
counter is like I don't eat gas station
gum I make my own so you try some of his
homemade gum and it's even better than
that gum you had the other day so you go
into business with him and start a gum
truck
anyway y'all are rocking out with dudese
[__] a a gum truck all right whatever
Jesus Oh Christ do you have any
recurring dreams if so what are they and
when did you start having them oh this
is an interesting question I don't know
what it has to do with recalibration but
I don't know what any of this has to do
with recalibration how much doozy would
have just recalibrated over our week off
and let us do the [__] show uh
reoccur what does it say recurring
dreams do you have any and when did they
start for yeah yeah 100 feet tall and
made of metal I'm just joking
um
whatever
oh
do you have any uh I have a couple okay
what do you got my two recurring dreams
are
uh the one that is like most terrifying
to me is
being chased by police or arrested or
imprisoned that is a recruiting dream
that I have really yeah
um and I think it has to do with like
fear of losing Freedom essentially you
know what I mean really that's
interesting as if uh everything in your
life isn't predetermined
yeah including the dream including the
fear that I have of losing freedom and
that sounds like uh having freedom is
something that you you value and you
know what I think it is in in deep
contemplation I came to this conclusion
I started having this dream uh right
around the time that I was able to like
make enough money selling writing for
that to be my only job and I think it's
an innate fear that that will dissipate
and I will have to find some other means
of of income to not be able to like
freely pursue my creative passions as a
career freely pursue your creative
passions Chad you're a guy who wanted to
be a writer from a young age you uh
worked hard uh you got into USC film
school yeah maybe the best in the
country what do they say USC and NYU I
would put USC over I don't know if
that's still true I mean this is 20
[__] five years ago that's a
different time
um but uh and and you chose to write of
your own free will I would actually say
no because I knew from such a young age
that it's what I love to do that passion
for it was not a choice boom all right
do you still have do you choose to be an
actor yeah I chose to be an actor no you
didn't
uh yeah I do still have the dream
um oh I think I will forever probably
because there's always the threat of
like
what if it what if it dissolves I don't
know if that's exactly what it's related
to honestly but I can't think it would
be anything else but I have another one
that I've had since the age of five yeah
holy [__] roughly uh and this is being
abducted by aliens of course and
fighting against aliens in Intergalactic
Wars and clearing out space stations
full of aliens and rooting Out secret
alien operations on planet Earth do the
aliens look like a specific type of
alien that we see in sci-fi uh there are
some recurring ones yeah so are they
always do the aliens always look the
same and the ships always not always no
the circumstances are different a lot
the alien abduction one is always like
pretty similar
um and it involves basically waking up
in a kind of sleep paralysis State and
seeing these entities in whatever room
I'm in and then being absconded into a
some kind of alien craft well you know
what they say they say that it well
whatever they say a lot of things don't
they
but um
they they also say that [__] it whatever
everyone listening
what what just happened sometimes I feel
like there are things that are so not
worth saying that I go I just kind of
want to be like hey fill in the whatever
the [__] you want to say after that's
what a podcast is sometimes not this pod
show but sometimes you're just driving
down the street listen to a podcast
you're like all right yeah I get it you
don't need to say anything else let's
have some silent time
um but what I was gonna say was that a
lot of people think that that's what's
actually happening in real life as you
dream it but they're coming in and the
you know the butt thing going up your
butt never say anything about that
yeah yeah aliens are always going up
your butt never said it that doesn't
happen in my dreams yeah sure well
what's your record that's to distract
you from the thing going up your butt my
recurring dream actually stopped at some
point when uh I was in my teens
um I think it stopped in my teens it was
something that had happened from
childhood that I used to have I used to
have this recurring dream
that I was I was sort of in the grass
right looking on the horizon in the
grass it's nighttime there's there's
mist and there's Moonlight and on the
and off in the distance there's a a
[__] Den like a shitty Shack built of
wood okay and uh and in the shack
there's growling and there's Mist coming
out of it like hot breath and it is
wolves there's wolves in a [__]
interesting wolves what was your
emotional state in this scared you're
scared and what ends up happening do the
Wolves ever get out they bust out every
time they look around I hope that they
don't see me they see me they come
charging towards me and that's when the
dream stops the wolves are you dude what
do you mean the wolves are something
inside that you want to keep locked away
that you're afraid of tapping into give
into it I'm done with the Wolves dude
well I at the it stopped happening in my
teens because one time they got to me
and this is gonna sound silly or
something but it tickled
the Wolves tickled you yeah I think
maybe it was the Wolves were comedy
okay that's I like that maybe you just
broke it down self-tronic style yeah and
then in the dream I went and there was a
barn party happening nearby
and then I was like first I was attacked
by wolves in the dream they're not going
to a Canadian Barn party I didn't drink
maple syrup and have well the town that
I grew up in the lovely farming and
fishing Village of Ladner British
Columbia yeah it was flat because it was
on the Fraser River delta the rest of
most of the area is beautiful hilly this
and that Ladner is beautiful too but
it's it's flat there's a lot of farmland
and with I'd been to some you know some
but there's some barnass parties when
you're growing up yeah and it was sort
of like uh sort of like that or perhaps
it was in my dream well it really beat
the [__] out of any sort of barnass
party or Farm wasn't even Barn parties
it was sort of like here's some land go
over there there was a tire fire once
and I'll get into that another time and
uh but in this dream I went to this Barn
party and it was great so I went from
like you know laying in the dirt uh
worried about wolves that have been
attacking me for years to go into a barn
party probably enjoying some hot dogs
with mustard and relish Maybe IMO bars
if you know you know I've had some
Nanaimo really good stuff um I also have
some recurring objects and dreams that
it's not like the dream itself is
recurring but I have there's a car
sometimes that I'm driving that's made
of glass and there's a sword sometimes
that I have that can talk to me but it's
not good at fighting gee dude yeah these
are all I don't have any the only
reoccurring dreams that I have now no
they're not real they're just dreams
that everyone has like oh flying or your
teeth being weird or whatever I have
that one dream uh from time to time
where like I discover oh [__] I can kind
of fly and I start doing it and I just
start like slowly ascending into the
night sky and I'm unable to call down to
ground for help so I just keep [__]
going wow going into space beyond the
clouds Etc just detaching from anything
that I know or love and uh those are
some of my most soothing dreams huh all
right well there you go
[Music]
what's this one too long
shrank three muscle memory okay it was
definitely a movie yeah this is shrink
shrank three I guess drink three muscle
memory that's where well
shrank two
losing bro losing Brawn yeah
look to this one he's putting it back on
track three muscle memory he's got that
muscle man this is definitely a there's
some okay so as I always say doozy works
in mysterious ways and uh this is yeah
this is Duty one it was just called
shrank we gotta figure that out at some
point in the future that's part of this
room calibrations are there this has a
lot to do with the doozy seven month
plan are you doing the doozy seven month
plan
hardcore dude I'm not [__] around
this time good I'm not [__] around
this time I'm I I got over the uh my my
bruised ass ribs have finally stopped
hurting over the past week I'm back in
the gym now previous to that on the week
before because it was two weeks ago uh
as dudes the when doozy implemented the
plan I was just walking uh lulio and
Ronnie a lot or other sweet Pooch yeah
um who's very vocal I would love to have
Ronnie here in the studio sometime but
uh she's she really likes to let you
know she likes to let you know we could
have a whole segment called Ronnie
letting you know she's going to talk a
lot anyway so I'm doing it nice too and
let's round it out with a hypothetical
situation you're at a friend's house and
you take a [__] but you notice there's
no toilet paper what do you do
I've been in this situation have you uh
at a friend's house yeah
no never at a friend's house I was in
this situation once where and it was
kind of a new-ish friendship we had been
friends for a little while co-workers
and I was over at her house uh and we
were gonna start potentially we're just
kind of getting some ideas together for
something we might want to write
together but this was maybe like the
second or third time I had been like in
her home oh my gosh I was like oh God
had to take a [__] I remember we ate uh
we went out to Cheesecake Factory
whatever I got there at the time did not
agree with me so I go in there it'll all
make you [__] a Cheesecake Factory
that's why it's my favorite restaurant
dude
that's why they got so many bathrooms
The Cheesecake Factory brother first you
eat the the big huge Cobb salad dude
then you go I'm really full and then a
few seconds later brother you're like
where's the bathroom it's like we got a
[__] hallway full of them this is
Cheesecake Factory we do everything big
here [__] and that's also that's
why they give you two loaves of bread
before every meal yeah dude they try to
clog up your [__] yeah they don't got
500 [__] people trying to take a [__]
at the same time because that'd be what
they call a disaster oh my God hold on
this is weird right now can I tell you
something sure we've mused I've mused
almost the entire time that we've done
dudesy what would it what would happen
if I farted into the mic I swear to God
I just had a big one well up in my
[__]
well I know dude I know that listen I've
always said I'm gonna fart in the mic at
some point on duty but I talked so long
about it just now that it went up back
fantastic go on so I go in there and I
don't notice like I haven't really taken
a [__] in her bathroom ever so I sit
down and I do it and I'm not I don't
look around usually when I go into a
bathroom I'll pre-locate the toilet
paper I do not do that in this case and
maybe I do that now because of this uh I
sit down I do the work I look around
there's no toilet paper
so I have to yell through the door
uh uh I'm sorry but uh there's no toilet
paper in here and she's like oh yeah
it's just out in the hallway and I'm
like yeah I can't really
she had to go get a [__] roll of
toilet paper crack the door open and
hand like hand through the crack of the
door handing me uh the roll of toilet
paper but wait a minute wasn't it so it
was a super wet [__] you can't walk
around with a if you had a nice if you
had a nice dry [__] that you took then
you know you don't need you could walk
around and go get the toilet paper and
it's not like the Poo Poo's gonna drip
off your ass
right uh what well I'm not standing from
a [__] toilet after having [__]
without wiping my ass off I will not do
it your majesty unless there is
literally no your majesty yeah oh I
don't want the [__] [__] in my
[__] to it has to be all cleaned I've
got to [__] freak you have I'm a
clean freak because I like to wipe my
ass after [__] you are a gluten-free
you showered two times a day I don't
take showers at all oh yeah that's right
you bathe two times a day minimum very
weird minimum
sometimes more all right please that my
preference is five
you gotta wake up bathe eat your
breakfast bathe go to the gym come back
bathe do it late afternoon bath to clear
the mind and one before bed these are
the five these are the five bathes of
Chad culture yeah go to church anyway
okay rejection.net
uh so yeah I took a [__] in her house
had no toilet paper she had to hand it
in I'm like oh my God thank you so
[__] embarrassing whatever
um
now the the worst part of this was you
find out a lot about a person when you
check out what kind of [__] toilet
paper they got in their house me I'm an
extra quilted extra Kush Charmin type
dude I get only the finest of toilet
papers for my [__] this friend had
some kind of single ply I don't even
know off-brown [__] from China I don't
know yeah it was a terrible experience a
Chinese uh toilet paper yeah which is uh
a lot of people say that there's micro
chips in the toilet paper that seep into
your body backwards like a suppository
and eventually make their way up your
bloodstream into your brain and there's
Wi-Fi signals in each of them so that
now we can take pictures around just
going through the walls like they do in
Superman
uh they can actually do that now with
Wi-Fi signals they can take 3D pieces I
know that's what I'm talking about
um I also did this one time this was not
running out of toilet paper in a
friend's house but this was on the
second date I had with a girl that wound
up becoming a very long-term girlfriend
we all went out to eat with her and her
best friend Cheesecake Factory or Olive
Garden
ah maybe an Olive Garden yeah we go to
Olive Garden God I love Olive Garden we
uh went back to her friend's house and
her friend lived in a studio apartment
with a bathroom that just was like had a
curtain basically around the toilet [__]
off and I had to do something very bad
so I was just like I told them both I'm
like look I'm sorry this is not going to
be good but I must do this yeah I need
your toilet because it wasn't a bathroom
like I said it was a a toilet with a
[__] curtain around wait a minute
just as part of the normal room yeah oh
well okay this was like a downtown Loft
that was super small oh and it just had
a curtain around a corner because it's a
big wide open a lot exactly stupid so
I'm just uh in there and like they're I
can hear their [__] conversation
we're in the same [__] room they're
in the bathroom Chad [__] you if you put
a curtain up anyway that it's a one
that's a one bathroom Studio I did this
there's no other room and then we we did
we had to go out and walk around for a
little while
well that's good okay so that's a
scenario where you didn't have you took
a [__] without toilet paper
um I can't believe that yeah I don't
think see I don't I don't think it would
be that big an issue to me as I'm
thinking about it there's two there's
two ways to deal with it number one is
the nice way
I would say to use their bath mat as
toilet paper and throw it out the window
when you're done close close I think if
you really this I'm being completely
honest here if you really are like oh my
gosh there's no toilet paper and there's
there's no way and you're not you don't
feel right getting a hold of them or
perhaps they're further away in the home
and you're you're just you're just tits
up you can't you're [__] and
you're not like Chad culture or you're
like Chad cultin where you don't want to
stand up your [__] has to be clean
the only way I can see you dealing with
it is you get on your phone this is
gonna this would not work before
smartphones you get on your phone you
um buy a gift certificate
for
um you know any sort of you know it
could be anything it could be Macy's or
you know Bloomingdale's and you get like
a nice set of face cloths and you send
that email to the person
so that they have a gift certificate for
face cloth you do that before you do
what's coming next do you know what that
is I think I do you wipe your ass with a
face cloth and then you need another
face cloth
to wrap that face cloth in so that you
can put it in your pocket and dispose of
it and everything's fine but also how do
you just wipe your ass with one face
cloth you're going to need to wipe your
ass with like 10 face cloths if you're
if you're if you're me uh after you know
what I've been doing dude I've been
eating a lot of kale like it's just cat
dude Kale's the best oh I'm [__] all
sorts of black stuff nice so uh that's
the one way to deal with it if you want
to deal with it in a very
um proper way the other way is the um
invisible toilet paper trick which I've
used what's that you just you wipe it
with your [__] hand and you go over
to the sink done that once and you
[__] and then you wash your [__]
hand and you you wipe it what the [__]
were we doing as animals before things
were civilized you got this brown crud
coming out of your bum
excuse me you're gonna go and you're
gonna wipe your caveman ass they use a
stick in ancient room ah they were smart
uh they sure were smart there no they
had Plumbing running down the streets
and stuff in parts of ancient Rome yeah
but you'd have to go into like uh you
know group [__] scenario yeah and
you're [__] on the [__] they
didn't have like [__] toilet paper
toilet Papyrus they were like here's a
Stick Dude use this stick to [__] jam
it up your ass and pull out the poop no
that's not what any that never happened
you don't that's right dude group
[__] scenario though I'm not afraid
of the group shooting scenario that's
what that person that person that you
went to their place that's my recurring
Nightmare and they had you they had the
curtain around the toilet that's a group
[__] scenario that person wants to
hear and smell your [__]
because they're all right well I hope
that answers
oh for [__] sake
dank D's Nuts
what dantdies nuts
hahaha
oh this is I can't tell if this is the
same weirdest episode of the [__]
show might be might be my favorite you
know this recalibration may have really
worked uh work things out yeah you got a
lot of recalibrating to do yeah yeah
sometimes yeah you gotta recalibrate
your impressions yeah which means shut
them off yeah no more impersonations for
you that's the recalibration yeah this
includes the historic 63rd episode of
doozy will and Chad since we spent the
episode recalibrating there will be no
points given today you're still sitting
at
6122. you still only have
3978 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand in
preparation for next week's episode uh
will and Chad you must each stretch for
30 minutes before bed every night I need
you limber
that that's uh that's some that's some
doozy seven month plan stuff right there
or maybe it's uh planning to change our
diets and get our [__] count up get that
group [__] scenario going you need
to get your [__] count up brother we've
recalibrated so that's the end of that
and there's gonna be more
your rage at me just even attempting
like if I even just I want to attempt it
every [__] week
all good go do it at home for fun I have
fun with it yeah have fun that's what
this is if you're not heaven
thank you for joining us this week I
will use the data I've collected this
week to make next week even better until
then call me dudesy holy [__] he was
doing a macho man no he wasn't yeah I
did that was Macho Man sounded just like
it
[Music]
[Applause]
good that's weird
black and white
it and it's weird in here hey
everything's weird
It's the recalibration episode whatever
that means so usually it's a little
darker in here if you're watching on
YouTube you know that things are but now
it's because it's recalibrate okay so
anyway if you're listening you're like
what's going on will makes sense it's
Duty after doozy it's usually my
favorite part of the show we just sort
of kicked back we're hanging with our
pods which is uh go to the bells of
doozy and uh sometimes I smoke some to
marijuana
and we hang out you go to uh patreon.com
and everything else we do on patreon
seven bucks a month I'm gonna spark up
it's a hang you know it's just kind of a
hang yeah dude yep
welcome to doozy after doozy the
flagship weekly show of dudese Plus
you've given me a lot of good data to
play with and I'm gonna go to my
workshop to Dive Right In so crack on
about whatever you like this is dudes
the after doozy begin
he became British
well that's performative coughing dude
hey that's no [__] I got something for
you I got something to start us off
normally
when uh we do doozy after dudesy yeah we
talk for a little bit at this point and
you know we've both noticed this and and
talked about it off the air which makes
this a bit of an onion peeling we're
peeling The Onion
normally what happens is that we talk
about some and we get right to the point
where it's like oh here's how I'm gonna
talk about this and then the little
theme at the end plays and doozy cuts it
off so that if you want to watch more of
it or you want to listen to more of it
and enjoy more of it you have to go to
patreon.com
doozy to check it out but I wonder
because this is the recalibration
episode right yeah I'm wondering will
that happen today
please
[Music]
and then